[Music]
foreign
brought to you by the every dollar app
start budgeting for free today Jeremy's
With Us Jeremy is in Tucson Arizona hi
Jeremy welcome to the Ramsey Show
thank you thank you for taking my call
sure how can we help
uh so quick question my son youngest son
got himself stuck into a whole life
policy
and of course I want to talk him out of
it and get him to invest in something
else
so I know the biggest Hook is he can
borrow against his policy
I know that with the 401K you'll get
penalized
which bleeds which may be mutual funds
which I don't know a whole lot about
so I was wondering what's the major
difference between the 401K
and a mutual fund that he may be able to
borrow against in the future
okay
um how old is your son
he's 23. okay
all right
um
well I I don't think
I mean number one let's just let's just
ask the question why is he going to
listen to you
well I've had really good really good
relationship with him and the whole
reason he got himself stuck in here was
because I kept pushing for
uh to invest to save money to think
about his future
yeah but then he picked a bad way of
doing it right and when you say Sean
this is a dumb way of doing it it's not
a good investment program what does he
say
oh I can borrow against it that's his
big hook yes okay well no one ever got
rich borrowing their Investments
right they invest them and they forget
them completely against it yeah you're
borrowing against it is not is not a
method of wealth building
that's a method of selling Insurance
crappy insurance
but it's not a method of wealth building
right and that's what got him in he was
actually looking for health
and disability and death insurance
is what is where he started looking and
then they hooked him on the whole life
policy yeah
so I mean my point is is that we can
answer your question a 401k is not an
investment it is how an investment is
treated for taxes typically inside of a
401k you're going to find mutual funds
so you have a mutual fund that's either
covered with a coat keeping it warm from
taxes and the coat is called a 401k or
an IRA or a Roth IRA or it has no coat
and it's out in the cold and has taxed
but in both cases it's still a mutual
fund could be the exact same mutual fund
and um but wealthy people don't build
their investments in order to borrow
against them
and so if he wants to become wealthy
he's picked a really bad way of doing it
number one borrowing against it number
two he's picked the probably one of the
worst Financial products alive today
and is the whole life policy because it
has a horrible rate of return in the
first three years that you pay 20 x 20
times more for the same amount of life
insurance so you buy a hundred thousand
dollar whole life policy you buy a
hundred thousand dollar Term Policy if
the hundred thousand dollar whole life
if policy is a hundred dollars a month
the hundred the hundred thousand dollar
Term Policy is five dollars a month
that's what research tells us so it's 20
times more expensive ninety five dollars
extra per hundred
okay now where does that go it goes into
an investment called cash value and so
you and the cash value has no build up
for the first two to three years they
keep one hundred percent of your
investment as commissions the first
three years you have zeros on your cash
value build up the first three years
well that sucks and once you get past
having a really front loaded horrible
commission off the front end it finally
starts making money the average whole
life policy according to research
averages 1.2 percent rate of return not
gonna get rich on that either oh and
then when you finally get past all of
that if you actually build it up you can
borrow and pay them interest to use your
money
so if you have a savings account and you
want to borrow and you want to take
money out of your savings account you
don't have to pay money you just take
money out of your savings account but
with a whole life policy you want to
take money out you have to pay them
interest to use your money that you paid
20 times more to build up this thing
sucks oh and it's even worse than that
you finally build up inside your whole
hundred thousand dollar policy twenty
thousand dollars worth of cash value and
then you screw around and die which we
all do
oh guess what happens to your 20 000
that you paid ninety five dollars extra
per month to build up after getting past
horrible rates of return and no and no
comma and no build up at all for the
first three years because they kept it
all as a commission once you finally get
20 000 in there and you die they pay a
hundred thousand dollars
they keep your savings account so if you
had a savings account at the bank and or
if I start pitching you a savings
account on Tick Tock and I said hey
here's your savings account the first
three years you put money in nothing
happens we keep it all after that it
makes 1.2 percent and when you die you
lose your money
no one would put money in that
that's a whole life policy so nobody
ought to put money in a whole life
policy so you can just play this rant
back for your son Jeremy when it comes
out on the podcast and it'll answer it's
perfect that's exactly what I would do
and I'm not even I mean that's exactly
Sun watch this yeah this is just don't
do it don't do it son of Jeremy you have
been screwed by the life insurance
industry and they are very good at their
business of screwing people it's
unbelievable horrible product let me
tell you if you're poor the way they get
you
is the pawn shops the way they get you
is the rent to own the way they get you
is the payday lender
the way they get you is lottery tickets
if you're middle class the way they get
you is they make you believe you're
going to get rich on airline miles using
your stupid credit card well that's a
dumb dumb butt idea
the way they get you is they get you
into a whole life policy that's a dumb
butt idea the way they get you is they
go sophisticated rich people lease their
cars no they don't
no they don't
so the whole life policy is the is the
payday lender of the middle class
it's a signal that you intend to be in
the middle class to stay there the rest
of your life because you got screwed by
the insurance companies
and I got to tell you man if you don't
like that and you sell whole life you
need to actually learn how your product
works and then if you have integrity
you'll quit selling that crap
because there's only two types of people
that sell whole life the ones that don't
understand it and the ones that are
Crooks because if you understand that
crap and you sell it you by definition
or a crook
because anybody that would sell someone
an investment that the insurance company
keeps their money that they put in there
upon death and call that a good deal is
a crook
that's just bull okay it's just absolute
scam stuff it just pisses me off and
I'll tell you what the I whole life I
thought it had just about gone away and
freaking Tick Tock has revived whole
life
Tick Tock of all things
I mean people listen people if your
social media sounds like a Tic Tac you
sh you know there's only one thing you
should listen to on Tick Tock and that's
stuff we put out but other than that
it's awful it's a Barren landscape of
morons that's great it's crazy
absolute nuts oh God and the whole life
stuff is all over it like they just
invented it yesterday yeah it's the
oldest Financial product ma'am the
financial planning commit Community
completely abandoned this garbage 35
years ago no one sells whole life life
insurance except life insurance agents
no one in the financial planning
Community believes in it we've all been
looking at it going you've got to be
kidding for decades
and now as stuff comes back on Tic Tac
it's unbelievable